hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines
today aside from these apartment
buildings and the occasional McDonald's
our work on the University campus slash
College slash hospital and though I
won't entirely finish it since I want to
leave the in more intricate details and
foliage for some other time which I'm
not quite sure yet when in the future
it's gonna be but it's not gonna be in
the very near future yet but I will
finish the basic design layouts and all
of the buildings in this campus and
hopefully be able to create some good
campus along the way because I sure have
never built or even imagined to try and
make a university campus in my life but
yeah hopefully at least my thought
processes during this video will be a
good insight anyway the basic idea
behind this university campus you can
already sort of see laid out over here
since I want to have that circle in the
middle sort of the very central plaza of
the university where I want to have the
most important buildings such as the
University Center and the library at
some point in the future and this
pedestrian Road which sort of extends
from its all the way to the corner code
and an official entrance of the campus
will be where I really want to add all
the buildings alongside as soon as
actually remove all of those parks
because I still don't have that mode
which allows you to get rid of the girls
that come with parks but yeah the very
idea of this campus is then to now even
though this is a campus which still has
a reasonable size make a campus which
still feels quite I would say
necessarily cozy but still atmospheric
not feel too large and intimidating and
at the very least the pedestrian
friendly I really want to make use of
shared space over here so this entire
Plaza and the pedestrian sort of
Boulevard you could say is going to be
used by just pedestrians and cyclists
some cars I suppose that really need to
use it but it's going to be mainly to
make sure that everything in your new
University can be reached from this one
sort of central place and everything is
not too far away and too
large even though they are still going
to be quite a large number of buildings
on this campus and I'll try to get the
necessary car and a little Transperth
sort of tucked away at the back of the
buildings not right here alongside this
little Bulevar since I really want to
make sure that you don't have to worry
about any car users and make this campus
much more accessible so really I'll lay
down all of the buildings nearly
alongside this brillo bar I do have to
say that since they were placed
alongside the road on the other side it
doesn't quite work with all the
buildings like some of the buildings at
least have a back which looks just as
good if not better than the front but
some buildings you can really tell that
you're looking at the back but
technically I sort of want the front of
the building to be facing the plaza so
that is an issue for a couple of
buildings like the high schools which I
sort of I'm using not as high schools
but it's overall I am quite happy with
how it works
as I lay out so far and most of the work
is definitely and trying to make the
paths look convincingly connected and
creating an atmosphere with planters
details alongside the paths and making
sure that all the buildings are easily
connected that way I really also just
went for this setup since it is quite a
compact set up and you don't end up with
buildings that are too far apart
everything is quite manageable from
either the train station or where the
future bus stops are gonna be and you
don't really need to use even your bike
to get to the other side of the campus
and it should at least make it not too
large and intimidating I hope there will
be a couple of buildings sort of outside
this central plaza of course but not too
many actually I really want to keep it
especially alongside here just so that
everything is sort of equal everything
can be seen from one place in in the
university and then it just feels a bit
more connected by that sounded way too
philosophical but yeah that's the
general idea behind this
purrs which I'm really bad at wording I
also really wanted to make this campus a
very shared space so not just endless
University buildings but also just
figured I would have the hospital in
here much like there is actually also a
medical campus in Rotterdam and I was
really just figuring a hospital in any
other place would have works within the
city but at least by keeping it over
here you add a bit of life to the campus
especially given how otherwise in
vacations you would have a pretty empty
place that's very dead also wanted to
have that quick Albert Heijn over there
just to make sure that you know just not
just students but at least you can shop
over here and you can tell it's pretty
yeah it's actually very popular already
aside from that of course that there is
a sort of shared feeling of all the
different types of buildings over here
although it's really just hypothetical
since many of these buildings are
technically high schools I just want to
ignore that facts for a second and
figured that many of these buildings
belong to many different faculties
within the university but they are all
sort of placed alongside the central
road there's no real idea of different
clusters of buildings or buildings being
very far apart in the university they
all sort of are along the same road very
close to each other and sort of feel
very equal and similar in that regard I
also just wanted to have a very quick
McDonald's and tank station over here
just because I should I should say
petrol station but yeah just because I
really figured I didn't want this to be
entirely empty and I didn't have a
McDonald's in this city yet and that is
probably a big sin when it comes to
making cities so yeah realistically I
really wanted to have a McDonald's over
here aside from that though I wanted to
add a small hill on this side just to
make sure that the people behind there
on the very newly built neighborhood
don't have too many issues with the
sound that the highway creates and you
quite often see especially in these
newer neighborhoods in the Netherlands
that there is this hill between the
highway and the living areas and in this
case it was especially handy because I
still haven't really found
any realistically touch highway barriers
which often see made out of concrete and
glass and really couldn't find those so
a hill it's really about the best option
I could have as a sound barrier for the
highway not really much else is going to
be added to this part I really figured
its most realistic if I just keep it
empty and not over decorated with
different types of foliage but really
just keep it empty and gross anyway
moving back to the university I also
wanted to make sure that since I have
this very very large space of just
pavement that I got some more trees in
there because if there's anything that's
really good at creating a nice
atmosphere and making an area feel quite
natural it's just by adding lots of
trees so really wanted to have that in
there in the future I definitely want to
add some more planters really just
adding the basic decorations and shapes
which I want to have over here but in
the future I definitely want to have
more foliage overall in the campus it
still feels a bit empty which i think is
mainly due to the fact that the
pedestrian streets in the middle of the
university is so wide and that plaza is
quite large so foliage wise I am far
from done even at the end of this
episode but you know overall I'm really
quite happy about it and have plenty of
gone in spaces in here as well and
there's sort of that balance that I also
wanted to strike with making the
University campus at least feel very
compact and dense and keeping all the
buildings quite closely packed together
and but at the same time at least keep
some distance for some gardens and some
paths and some more relaxed areas in
between them and there was also this
idea of I really wanted to have these
larger plazas and areas where you could
walk around and relax at but also really
wanted to have these more grassy areas
and forests and parks so really wanted
to find the balance between that as well
which I'm not sure if I have entirely
hit it because especially the pedestrian
Plaza in the middle does feel quite wide
and I may very well in the future and
that's my current planning add some
extra planters especially for trees in
the middle in the middle there to at
least make the foliage a bit more dense
other than that's the foliage and
decorations are quite straightforward
it's really just a park-like set up with
different paths different curved paths
from gravel with some benches and some
areas to relax and what I probably
should have done a little bit more if I
look back at it in retrospect is at some
of these artsy style sculptures as much
as I'm not a really big fan of them it's
something you do see quite often and
something which I could have gone into a
little bit more but yeah that's all in
hindsight's that's definitely something
I still want to get to in the entire
campus but yeah like I said I really
just wanted to get the overall shape
done over here and this area over here
is really the main place to be not just
in how I wanted to decorate it and that
fountain and benches for people to sit
and I don't know spend their spare time
in but also really where I wanted to
focus the most important buildings
around so it's logically also the most
the place where you can most easily
access every single other part of the
university and another part which I
haven't really talked about about how I
wanted to set up this University campus
is something that I sort of wanted to
make the edges feel very non existence
like slowly make it a transition into
the rest of the world by ending these
larger areas of grass and slowly making
it less dense around the edges and
actually having more parks around there
I really wanted to make sure that the
campus wouldn't feel too closed off on
its own an important thing I think is to
keep in mind that your campus for me at
least a campus shouldn't be very closed
off and if you like its own institution
which doesn't well welcome any people
from the outside so really wanted to
make sure that there are sort of parks
and roads around the edges which connect
the outside world to the University and
sort of slowly gradually transition from
the parks
empty grasslands outside of the
University into where all the buildings
are located also very importantly I
added a bier Garten over there because
this is a university campus so I
definitely need some place where the
beer can flow I figured I was a pretty
important parts ahem but yeah as I've
said before and really never really went
into I just sort of picked buildings
which I figured fit most over here but
that does mean that it's all just sort
of a fantasy and it doesn't in the game
realistically actually reflects a campus
since for instance that its newest small
building that I added was really just a
I don't actually know the English word
for it how I don't even know the Dutch
words
puts that's that's a place where you get
work not quite sure where that's call
again or many of these buildings are
just high schools or technically office
buildings but oh well they are all used
by faculties of universities in this
case at least that's the idea here is
also where you can probably see the most
of an influence that I got by being
inspired by some Dutch universities that
took quite a bit of inspiration from the
University of Wageningen especially with
the larger square empty grasslands
around this campus also quite a bit of
inspiration from Utrecht which also sort
of has this grid like set up and also
really has this sort of central Lane
going through it even though in that
case the central Lane is used by cars
which I really wanted to avoid in this
case and use space instead which is all
the rage but yeah I really feel it's
quite a good thing to use and there was
one final thing I think you're actually
quite funny was that I got multiple
comments about maybe looking at the
university of Tilburg which actually
also sort of shares this grid like a
makeup but it is a university with much
more foliage really feels like it's in
the middle of the forest and as much as
I wanted to work with parks around this
campus I wanted to avoid turning it into
a real forest forest fest since well the
idea of this entire city is that it's
located somewhere in South Holland and
you don't really see too many forests in
South Holland
really wanting to keep the area quite
open and grass Blainey as you would call
very often see in this type of area also
really just very quickly added a small
bicycle bridge over there though that
something I might change in the future
really just a simple thing but their own
actually I don't think there are any
bicycle bridges on your workshop which
are very fancy and made with 3d models
might want to look into that but yeah
this is just perhaps a placeholder
perhaps something I'll keep in the
future because truth be told yeah this
this although this campus was made with
the idea of different ways of transport
in mind that's also something which I
haven't added yet and I still need to
get to adding the bus stations to the
University some place where buses can
drop off and pick up people because I
haven't even started doing that yet but
I want to do that in a future episode in
which I add the bus lines and do some
overall public transport then there are
also some bicycle paths obviously there
is that one path which is supposed to
connect this University to what is going
to be a future town which I think I'll
start work on in the next episode and
there is obviously of course also this
bicycle path over here which is going to
connect it to the centre of the city
and of course there's also the train
station which directly connects to the
train station near the center of the
city itself so hopefully in terms of
transport it should at least be good
let's add this entrance of the
University there are sort of two
entrances this one and the main entrance
which leads directly into that large
boulevard going through the middle of it
I do want to change them both in the
future a little bit make them a bit more
open and over here remove this real
retail park because I really figured
this would be a good place for a real
retail park but looking back at it and
looking at the fact that it's so close
to the stadium which I have over there I
think a sports park would be much better
and perhaps a good attempt to actually
have some sports parks for the
university but also combine that with
the sports and entertainment park which
is going to be here for the city in
general so that's actually something I
want to change in the future know that
I'm really
unhappy with this retail pike over here
but that's something I'll move to some
other more open part of the city at some
point in the future anyway that is going
to be about it for the time lapse for
today but I do still have a small rear
real time parts in which I only show off
the University so I'm handing it over to
my past self here so this is how things
currently look I don't show it off too
much yet since it's a little bit
unfinished I feel like the point where I
now need to get to is to actually make
it alive this is definitely the overall
layouts that I want to use and the
different buildings that I'm gonna use
but I really feel like it's something I
like to refer to in rollercoaster [ __ ]
as well it's it's it's finished but it
doesn't have the touches yet of human
activity like it'd need some lamps here
in their benches litter bins and also
some kiosks with people just selling
random stuff and trying to promote
products and things like that a bit of
liveliness to it but overall I'm quite
happy about it and it's pretty much
finished this way only a couple of
things that I do also want to work on in
the future is I might want to get a bus
stop either over here or over here but
that'll really come as soon as I stop as
soon as I start adding bus lines into
this city once the entire central road
network is all finished and the train
station still needs stuff next to it
like parking places but especially the
bicycle stands which is quite important
for the Netherlands and also some more
shrubs and decorations around the paths
and stuff like that is something like
two and a half yeah more thorough
explanation of what it's actually like
this is sort of the main Boulevard and I
really wanted to make a campus and to be
quite honest I don't have any experience
with making any type of campus but this
was very much inspired by the campuses
of bargaining Utrecht and that I've
already mentioned but I wanted to make
sure that this university at least had a
campus that was very pedestrian friendly
and so all the buildings most of the
buildings can be connected with one big
pedestrian Plaza over here with lots of
space but there's also some green spaces
and the cars are sort of at the back of
everything and make sure that you can
get everywhere by car but the main focus
is base
click on making this very
pedestrian-friendly and that's really
the entire idea and this is sort of the
central plaza for the entire university
with these buildings sort of in a quasi
symmetrical setup like that I'm quite
happy about it
it's spaced out but it doesn't really
feel too empty and I think it's the type
of campus that I could see myself
walking around in anyway next episode
I'm gonna actually know I'm lying about
that next episode will be a bit of a
jump in time since right now I want to
take a bit of time off screen and work
in some details not just the details of
the University campus and also some
details of the entire city things like
for instance the train line doesn't have
any fences next to it so people can just
walk right onto the train line I want to
add some more lights on these parts some
custom lights and benches and things
like that just little decorations all
over the city which I figured wouldn't
really look too great in a time-lapse
and I just want to work on right now so
yeah that's what I'll be doing and in
the next episode I have no idea what I'm
actually gonna record so thanks for
watching I suppose and see you later